Hey Stephen um it's Gerald Morgan here's
the song I promised um yeah please don't
show it to any anybody else man my wife
going to kill me uh I hope you like it
I'm just a little bit caught in the
middle my club back and it gave me a
tickle I don't know what to say all I
know is that I'm not gay and I don't
know why my wife plays along to the
silly little moments it bugs me kind of
but I don't show it I can't figure it
out it's bringing me down I know I've
got to let it
go and just enjoy the show The Mug is
blue the coffe is hot and we're never
going to stop the people follow all the
signs t.m. Eastern is the time it's all
the jokes you want to see that's why
mother clubs the place to
[Music]
be I'm just a little bit caught in the
middle my clubs back again it gave me a
tickle I don't know what to say all I
know is that I'm not gay I'm not gay I'm
not gay I am the CEO and I demand
respect look none of this happens if you
don't join mug club and do it lc.com
mugclub 89 annual you get the mug and
you get other stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
join
[Music]
I
wow that's a that's necessary hot tea
today uh because everyone here for some
reason the Bubonic plague has made its
way across the office it has uh which is
you know that's not why I wasn't here
Monday we had a you know we work on
things behind the scenes but then
yesterday I said I would go in but I
can't hear ear and I still can't hear in
my left ear today oh no that's the
headphones we're messing with you what
ah so uh we have a lot to get it's just
that congest have you have you it maybe
it's co who knows uh you comment below
if you've had Co recently just don't get
tested please don't get tested because
then the Communists win
so today we're going to be talking about
quite a few things I know everyone else
is talking about the speaker race we'll
touch on that but guess what doesn't
really matter that much what do I mean
you can't affect it okay bring up the
scorecard there uh toolman we also be
talking about the first ever non-binary
trans referee that's redundant I should
just say trans
referee and then uh Gaza right now
people are talking about how there is no
fuel in Gaza because of Israel um the
truth
is incorrect wrong boom sorry not the
truth is incorrect that is incorrect the
truth is you are hearing a lie and we
are going to do a segment tomorrow so
tune in tomorrow on uh the actual this
long-standing myth that Israel doesn't
allow the Palestinians to uh have access
to their own water that's not true
something the media were GG but more
importantly today as we talk about all
of this I like to discuss things that
you can control or things that we can at
least to some degree U have a positive
impact when we discuss it property taxes
this is something that right now may not
be on your radar but as we go into
elections people campaign on it and they
try and throw out some red meat lines
property taxes where they go how they
affect you and really how it's
effectively long-term theft so my
question to you is how much do you pay
in property taxes where do you think the
money is going and do you feel like
you're getting ripped off of course the
answer to the last one is yes but I ask
that you show your
work all right that's fair number two
CEO Gerald how are you I'm doing
fantastic I have a I have a new I have a
new lens now I don't have the fisheye
lens yeah but it looks like you're in a
it looks like you're in hell it's all it
all has a red tint yeah but I have the
American flag behind me so that's that's
a it looks like you're burning the flag
but I'm not I know you're not but it
looks like you are why is that look at
me and look at him it's a red tint
you're not that pink do I have a red Hue
you look like one of those those
lobsters Tim are you doing this on
purpose are you punking me right now no
you're making it seem like like a Hamas
video from hell all right and then in
third shair today when you hear this you
know who it is he's going to be at the
Chicago improv Friday and Saturday the
27th and the 28th and now his show off
limits right here on mug Club is moving
to Tuesdays that's news to me but I'm
glad he makes it work Brian Kalen how
are you sir I'm good give give your
listeners a a second to stop cheering
and I'll tell you how I'm doing I'm I'm
not I'm not congested yeah you are you
guys good by the way do you love how he
demanded that we make a promo for off
limits that look like Steve Jobs bring
it up again bring it up again it was a
photo I found in my I bring to you the
new off
limits yeah that that was taken by my
friend Aaron I I I don't remember taking
that though oh yeah are you a
fruitarian do you have shoes on I'm a
fruitarian and I and I have no furniture
in my home I sit on the floor do you
know what a fruitarian is yes it's where
you just eat fruit from the tree no no
no you only eat no see you're incorrect
admonish him admonish him I hope he does
a lot better on off limits I know tell
you what you are well within the limits
right now okay I don't know what you do
with your off limits but fruitarian is
where you only eat the fruit that has
already fallen from the tree because
that means it wants you to spread it
seed it's the only way to live Harmon
really cuz what I do is I take the fruit
from the tree but then I I poo outside
doesn't matter really fruitarian only
the fruit that has already it's the kind
of crazy that has Freud shuffling paper
saying I don't have a form for this year
sharian I mean sorry yes I do I do that
from pardon my language no it's a it's a
full word it's not the word you think
word well either way you guys are all
congested and I just want everybody to
know that my my head is clear but my
heart is full yes my heart is full but
if you're fruitarian you'll die young he
shuns traditional cancer treatment by
the way I don't know if we're there yet
but if at any point today while you're
watching on YouTube and you see
this head on over to rumble and watch on
Rumble and of course you get to keep
watching mug club with one click on
Rumble we're just on YouTube because you
know a lot of you still hang out there
and you should be ashamed of yourselves
but I get
it we're about to head into YouTube dump
territory because this is our first just
as a pallet cleanse here is a uh
transgender uh qu quad ampute is that
the term ampu quad it's a yeah it's I
would call it a a a quadruple ampute
quadruple ampute see that's why he's
there's nothing's off limits yes I was
well no a pentle a pentle amput would be
a oh okay all right I don't think that's
a real thing well if you lost your never
mind so quadruple ampute
te I I I almost feel uh we're we're
we're going to be in the river sticks is
doing a viral trend on Tik Tok and I
said thank you
[Music]
Bab
p
[Music]
h
f
[Music]
like look I've already lost the other
four things that kick that's why I said
pent that's why I S A pentle so bad I
can't count to pent I can only go quad
and then I skip pent and I go to hex you
didn't pay attention in Latin dude I
didn't I didn't I didn't and I speak
French and that's my fault because all
the romance languages are based in Latin
so wait tell me more about romance
languages you I love romance yeah I know
I know you seek it so trans but but it's
not cuz it's not off limits with Brian
it's not not everything so here's
another thing I stand by that name that
was a segue into Monday in by the way
and of course a stunning Act of Ry
everyone AG stunning stunning beautiful
Act of Bravery uh CH Shay Flores has
come out as the first ever NBA uh
nonbinary trans nonbinary is the term
they use referee and by the way before
we move on with this we actually have a
video of the referee in
action what
a I want to see it again this could be
that's as good as anybody anywhere
Brandon KN just just off limits that's
that's off limit seriously you know
where your limits are and I'm not
talking about my amazing podcast on
Tuesday hit the like button if you're if
you don't think it's quite fully
stunning and brave right because we deal
with Nuance here
so here's a decision to come out we're
gonna get to the speaker stuff that
really doesn't matter kill me
man on Z's decision to come out Chay
formerly Cherry my God it's not very
creative you just chopped in the water
said well that's I mean come on that's
going the other way says one piece I was
missing for myself was that no one knew
how I
identified it's Max
Holloway being misgendered as she her
always just felt like a little jab to
the gut I can now go through the world
and even my job a lot more comfortably
and uh this person came out because this
is how you know that people are super
oppressed um how many how many puff
pieces 3700w puff pieces have you heard
uh read from uh GQ on referees in the
NBA so this person formerly female
referees article about a referee this is
fascinating yes that's why I subscribe
to gentleman's quarterly yeah yeah a
little jab although really we just had a
quarter gentleman so I like that it's a
little Jab a jab to the gut but just a
little a little jab to the gut I me that
that hairstyle is a jab to my gut please
come on now that's off limits if it was
the previous person though it would just
be a jab to the everything cuz that's so
3700w puff piece in GQ and I know this
seems but here's the thing this is how
they try to slowly continually condition
you where oh oh yeah sh yeah female
referee yeah yeah of course and referees
are the real heroes that's why we have
write ups and you know time uh the
language from the article is conf
confusing and this just shows you people
can't even play by their own rules it
says but in September ahead of the trip
to Brooklyn for the NBA referees annual
preseason meetings Flores realized they
could do things more on their terms this
time in the past they might have made a
trip to the mall to get some unflashy
polo shirts and khakis professional
clothes that in their words I'm never
freaking going to wear again so this is
this is the issue that we run into so
this is trans okay but
plural not binary trans
[Music]
not
a y change you had the opportunity to
change your name change it to something
that everybody can anounce and by the
way do you think like what was going
through her head is like I'm one of like
only maybe a handful of female referees
in the NBA and they're like ah we've got
eight female referees now she's like
dang it I need something else I'm the
first non-binary trans but I also love
how this person is a man but like also
still making the caddy women comments
I'm never wearing unflashy polo shirts
and khakis again refere refere shut up
as a lesbian which is I think really
what's going on here I have nightmares
about being an NBA referee actually just
nightmares about being in prison but I'm
surrounded by black guys
now now one man's nightmares another
man's you're talking fantasy you're
going in the outer rims cuz it's not off
limits see that you see
that this area is off limits guys and by
the way you guys are going to need to
hit the YouTube dump button just on this
very last word we are going to play on
mug
[Music]
we can never do here on YouTube make
sure that butt was well and Rumble we
can but you know we take your chats and
stuff okay they hit it so the house
Speaker race look this is a genuine
question do you care and I say this
because uh first off we try to not
discuss things uh at length on the show
over which you can have no uh
appreciable effect mhm you're not voting
on this and I I know what this process
looks like to be clear it is a bunch of
phone calls favors quid proquo and this
is why you end up with speakers most of
the time even people who you like before
they become speaker they end up being
compromised and you say oh man I really
was thinking we'd nail it with that one
this isn't really something you can have
a huge effect on and so it kind of is
it's like sports betting it doesn't
matter the combination of ring dings and
pretzels that you eat at home you're not
going to change it your job is to elect
your representative so that hopefully
there's a better pool from which to draw
at this point this is the swamp making a
swampy decision and hopefully you end up
one with one who's not as swampy as the
rest right that's what you hope this is
more of like a spectator sport right now
but because they're covering it we just
want to give you guys a couple of
insights because they're trying to make
it look like the Republican party is in
disarray when they're not wrong on this
one oh and by the way really quickly
before we talk about jenet Ellis and
before we talk about Cohen and we talked
about Sydney pow here's the thing you
need to The Plea system in our country
needs to to go away we need to change
that system just to be clear we've
spoken with a lot of these people they
absolutely 100% believed what they said
back then and now they're just trying to
get out from an aggressive Federal
Department of uh investigation that's
what it the doj the doj doj FBI they're
all involved so to say oh these people
yeah they're they're they are turn coats
yes a lot of these people are cowards
but I can tell you this they didn't make
it up they didn't make it up how do we
know because we were in communication
with people back then and by the way a
lot of what they discussed that was
correct a lot of the
corre ising their ass that's it it's not
that B of A Story it's a corrupt justice
system it is not white black it is about
those who want to put a Target on your
back and they will make it so all right
so maybe we'll talk about it more
tomorrow but right now looks like
representative Tom emmer it would have
been would have been yeah next as far as
a speaker of the house House Republicans
have nominated majority whip Tom emmer
as the next Speaker of the House in a
series of secret ballot votes uh this is
the third time in as many weeks that
Republicans have nominated a new speaker
but so far none have been able to Garner
enough support to win the gavl okay so
you know we've talked about this right
now as far as the nominee is going to be
Donald Trump most likely and of course
the selective prosecution it's a Witch
Hunt right now uh and I really would
like to see the Republicans actually
standing in the pocket and doing the
right thing because they will come for
you next that is not to say that he is
without his flaws this is kind of an
example now it's more so p
so let's go through the timeline Monday
at 1:33 uh p.m. Trump said that emmer
was his quote biggest fan uh but he said
that he was going to stay out of it so
consistency is not a strong suit here
you go well I think he's my biggest fan
now because he called me yesterday told
me big stand so I don't know about that
uh well we're looking at a lot of people
and you know sort of trying to stay out
of that as much as possible but they'll
get it straightened out okay so he's
going to stay out of it yeah all right
he doesn't want to tip the scales this
guy formerly wasn't as biggest fan that
was right before the audio that we came
in and now he called him yesterday and
apparently he's his biggest apparently
he's his biggest fan there was a phone
call all right so then Tuesday Morning
Ember won some successive ballots behind
closed doors but then Tuesday at 1 p.m.
1:11 to be clear if you need a fact
check me 26 Republicans voted against
emmer in another closed door meeting
whoops and uh while his failed bid was
sort of becoming public that's when
Donald Trump who was going to stay out
of it posted on Truth
social can't help himself can't help
himself up and he's like 100% right do
you think he do you think he just has
elastics on his hand where like look
just smack he's like I don't need this
elastic so I think things stew I think
he just kind of like festers and he goes
I can't anymore he was saying I want to
stay out of it but he's my biggest fan
that was him saying hey you know what
maybe you should try and buy for my
endorsement and when he maybe didn't
Donald Trump posted on Truth social I
have many wonderful friends wanting to
be Speaker of the House righto Tom Emer
who I who I do not know well is not one
of them folks he actually spent more
time defending Anon Omar can you believe
it that he did me
Trump I believe he's now learned his
lesson because he is saying that he is
pro Trump all the way but who can ever
be
sure voting for a globalist rhino like
Tom Emer would be a tragic tragic
mistake that's what he said apparently
he knows him well enough to know he's
been defending Anon over to stay out
he's very subtle at least we know that
yeah exactly he's rather poetic and
metaphoric and then then at Rhino
globalist then at
123 uh uh I guess Florida representative
um Anna Pina Luna wrote on Twitter uh
what did what did she write Gerald she
was writing that she voted for rep
Donald's for speaker Follow by Johnson
and that emmer does not have the votes
to be speaker and so she would be unable
to support him on the floor and then
three hours later emmer drops out of the
speaker race dunzo and of course the
media did not hesitate to make the
connection between Trump's post Emmer's
demise right this whole thing so just so
you it doesn't matter who you are if you
are someone who becomes culturally
relevant the media will make it about
you I don't know that Donald Trump had a
huge effect on this I do think that it's
childish and either stay out but it's
trumpish or be in but it is pretty funny
it's part for the course and it's worse
than we realized because we actually
have the exclusive oh yeah sometimes we
get these you know we have our hidden
camera journalists or investigative
journalists we have the exclusive
voicemail that President Trump left for
emmer please record your message hey
emmer you love big time you see what
happens when you're not in the Trum
trade you're on the tracks and I'm the
conductor Choo Cho can you hear the Trum
trade CH people around the world say Dr
trade ever lost his time for the Dr
trade I'm sure you're fine at some
things Emma don't take it personally
you're probably very good at things like
frankly sucking because you do that's
what a lot of people say I would never
say that myself they all come to me they
say Hey you know that Emma guy he's a
real loser and he's sucking one time I
walked in a room they say this I say
don't say that they say I walked in a
room and he was sucking a guy I say
that's horrible he is for everyone
thinks you're a loser M is for B
everyone thinks you're a loser e is for
why I did that one already loser or is
you're r a loser ever I think you get
the message frankly maybe you're too
dense you suck
emmer you lose sucking emmer they call
you who leaves voicemails anymore I know
and that wasn't very presidential you
know what I mean but I kind of like it I
do too but I just I mean if he sucks
like literally then well you know and is
you know what is there someone who you
think would make a good speaker they
someone even outside of Cong it can be
someone just who you think would be a
good speaker I guess that's about the
only value you can add at this point you
have a good teacher when you were in
school let's nominate them yeah let's
nominate them they're the real heroes
please so all right want to go on to
Gaza yeah
okay beautiful because why not when you
watch it they're talking about this oh
is it going to be this per it's so silly
it's so silly there's so much that you
can do to affect your day-to-day life
when this show is done check the
references we make them available move
on with your life when people say you're
living in a Sim people will try and say
this right like I watched The Matrix
once are you living in a simulation and
look it's not about you basically are
let me ask you this how many
interactions do you have with a person
on a screen each day versus how many
interactions that are mean ful do you
have with someone in real life every day
you will be in front of the people who
matter most to you who will at on your
deathbed you will wish you spent more
time with these people they in a room
and you were on your phone watching some
quadruple ampute Tik Tock just shut it
off who gives a after our show
after our show well it used to be used
to be people spent their day they went
to bed watching Carson they watched
something that's what we want to be you
watch the show okay educate yourself but
the scrolling that's the simulation
you're living in you are living in a
fake reality yeah that's true it's
horrible I know but horrible so addicted
what people say the problem is you
you're you've got a whole day and then
you're like what is this This Woman's in
a bikini on a skateboard I got to make
sure she's safe and then you're like you
know 40 minutes later you're still not
me because I have my Jiu-Jitsu and my
meditation yes yeah exactly sure you do
you don't know I can't do the
Transcendental Meditation I tried it
once yeah I tried it once and it didn't
work because they were being too
descriptive like you picture a Stairway
I was like what kind of a like and you
picture nice railing I'm like you're not
saying is it wood is it steel is it some
kind of an alloy like I just I kept
falling asleep concentrate focus on your
breath I was like I can't do it I know I
know snoring all right let's go to Gaza
let's go to Gaza speaking of kung fu
Dude where's my fuel they say a so if
you've watched the mainstream media you
you probably have heard and this is
something out there this is the claim
that that Israel is keeping Gins from
obtaining any kind of fuel that they
don't have any fuel you've heard this
throughout the media they just were
talking about shutting down hospitals
because of it
yes the power is flickering and fading
at hospitals in Gaza as medical
officials say generators are on their
last drops of fuel the health system run
by Hamas is in a state of collapse and
you can just hit this as a collage right
there the UN is reporting that fuel
supplies are running out of hospitals
there's no fuel being trucked in from
Aid convoys to Gaza okay here's the
truth Hamas actually the People by the
way who were elected by the folks
by the way the majority of Palestinians
to this day have a favorable view of
Hamas which is unfortunate they have
plenty of fuel so before I get Ju Just
so you know it's true when we make all
of the references available Reuters and
they really hate the Jews Reuters even
reported the story with this headline
Israel's military tells un and Gaza ask
Hamas for fuel meaning they're claiming
that well Reuters isn't it your job to
verify aren't you fact Checkers it's
surprising that Reuters would even
mention this considering their history
history with and I don't they hate the
Jews so
2010 writers even remember the fla
picture they edited out a knife being
used by a Turkish activist against an
Israeli soldier this is when the fla was
going on this was I think it was 2000
there was another conflict bring that
back up yeah bring it see that that
knife right there that man who's being
held at knife Point what you see is what
is edited out in the Reuters headline in
2010 just to give you an idea as to how
biased it wasow wow they cut it out so
you don't see the knife that's kind of
the important part of the picture it's
amazing to me that somehow when you've
got we know that they the Hamas came in
and killed entire families in their
pajamas and much worse we have video of
it cuz oh yeah they were videoing it and
and somehow we have to whiteash the fact
that they're not that bad they would
never use a knife or keep fuel from
their that's 2010 and today they're
going well Israel claims okay hold on a
second would there be some kind of a way
to verify and I get it people are saying
that there's an incentive for
misinformation on both sides that is
true but some things can be verified
yeah do you have reporters on the ground
I don't know isn't this the job of the
media is to go hey a hospital was bombed
wow that's terrible let's go look at it
and see if we can report on it so the
world can be outraged and put pressure
instead they're just like yeah I'm on
said it we'll take their word for it
yeah yeah and by the way if there if
there is a shortage of humanitarian Aid
fuel all these different things why is
Egypt keeping that from them I I want to
I want to turn this a little bit because
it's not just Israel like why is well
let me get to the TR so the truth is
that the reason they said ask Hamas uh
the IDF is because there are photographs
and I get these are from the IDF but let
me come back to this they show that
Hamas is hoarding over 500,000 lers of
fuel oh so they're stealing by the way
what humanitarian fuel I think we even
have a clip from
CNN fuel unfortunately is essential for
the Kamas military machine they need it
for their Rockets they need it for their
underground Terror network of tunnels
and we understand that and we had a
documented case last week where where
fuel I think six tankers CNN reported
went in through the rougher Crossing
with Egypt and then that fuel a large
proportion of it and it was said of
course the fuel's going to generators in
hospitals to help save lives and yet
Kamas at gunpoint stole a large
proportion of that fuel and then we
presume it was diverted to their
military machine now now I get easy talk
I get what some of you say IDF you can't
trust them okay but they they put out a
tweet showing aerial footage of the fuel
reserves okay and this is a tweet where
it says this what more than half a
million liters of diesel in hamas's
possession uh in uh hamas's possession
sorry appears ellipses which continues
to make its claim of its inability to
supply hospitals bakeries and civilians
with fuel residents of Gaza do not make
any demands on Israel um you basically
should ask Hamas right and here's the
thing this is not new keep in mind and
we'll talk about this tomorrow uh in
Palestine they have the abilities right
now internationally paid for to at least
double very likely triple their water
capacity paid for by International
governments and agreements by the way
desalinization plants uh places to to
set up pipes but the last time they were
given these supplies they use the pipes
to turn them into rockets and to bombs
Hamas did that yeah so to blame your
enemy of War for not giving you water in
fuel which to me is absolutely insane I
mean let's just speak we're going to
discuss that tomorrow in depth that is a
long-standing myth that people buy
hookline it's not even close to True
right now there would be no water issue
there would be water shortage for the
people of Palestine if not for Hamas and
just to be clear we've been in contact
with some people at the IDF who've sent
us specifically some footage now it's
publicly on YouTube they've offered to
speak with us on record but I want to be
clear I would love to have someone from
uh Hamas from uh some Palestinian
representative organization an
ambassador I would love to have them on
immediately after uh a senior member of
the IDF tomorrow this week you can send
in your information to lwc tips at
protonmail.com
we'd love to have you on and provide the
opportunity to correct the record now
not what happens with Pierce Morgan
where they just go on there and they say
oh really why do you believe Israel they
lie they lie they lie they lie well tell
us how it's a lie give us some right now
if that footage is dishonest from the
IDF there are people out there who can
dissect us who can say it's AI they know
they can spot deep fakes before it
reaches your screen no one's no one's
actually disputing the authenticity the
only ambassadors who I have seen from
the Palestinian people Representatives
Hamas basically have just said it's not
through why do you believe the Jews well
hold on a second first off we can why
should we trust you and refute the
evidence I haven't seen anyone do it
I've seen people say we know that this
is the Jews who bum the hospital well
there's been a ton of evidence provided
from from Al jaaz by the way yes from
the International Community yeah
International intelligence also
crowdsourced International intelligence
I haven't seen anything to say that it
was Israel the only people who make that
argument are the people who are team
Hamas team Palestine no matter what send
it to me send me what we're missing what
being left out here you know they just
found there were two hostages taken a a
12-year-old um autistic girl and her
grandmother they were found dead by the
way they were they were murdered uh
today so let's leave all those
atrocities aside why are we not talking
about the fact that this operation that
Hamas pulled off took two years to plan
it took two years plan they had a
network of phone communication in those
tunnels so they have been at war with
Israel actively for two years October
7th was just the was just the final
culmination and the execution of that
that took crazy amounts of planning and
their job was to come in and wreak as
much hav Havoc against the civilian
population which they did right so uh
they're reing it against their own
civilians right now they would rather
play victim in the public and go look we
have no water well hold on a second what
about that water you don't know wait
well look are people have no fuel what
about those 500,000 liters there the
Jews lie they they lie every no and
that's all that's literally the
equivalent of saying well you are one
too I know Jews are but what am I yeah
exactly no and that that's the point
that I'm rber you are
Jew that almost Works um I I wanted to
touch on that because that's their
playbook right so it's not just what
they're saying it's what they're
physically doing Hamas would rather have
hospitals run out of fuel so that they
could have a photo op and they could
have a story run in the media than
actually take care of their own citizens
we know this they've used kids as human
Shields they used playgrounds and
schools as places launch rockets from
next to mosques and churches they
absolutely 100% do this and then they
did finally thank goodness Egypt allowed
three convoys into Gaza for Aid I don't
know how much of that Aid is actually
going to make it to the people because
right now Hamas just wants the world to
think they're being starved they have no
water and they have no fuel so the
hospitals are having to they run it they
are milici they're doing it to they're
doing it to their
population rise up look I I it's not
lost on me that if you're born right in
Gaza and you you're raised with this
you're going you're going to hate the
Jews because everything is blamed on the
I understand it and I understand that
it's not the fault of those children I
get that I understand that those
conditions are horrible I understand
that but let me ask you this do you
honestly think that in a time of War
it's the job of your military to provide
Aid and Comforts to your
opponent I let's just be real do you
know what war is even if you absolutely
hate Israel like fine why is it
incumbent upon them to provide water and
to provide
gasoline seriously war is meant to be as
unpleasant it's like prison it should be
as unpleasant as humanly possible it's
it's meant you're meant to be defeated
in prison you're meant to be punished
not saying it's a good thing I'm not
saying that Israel isn't hard absolutely
just rougher than sometimes maybe you
might think they need to be but it is
war this I I don't know maybe that's me
Mr traditional I don't understand why
you would go to war with someone and not
try and absolutely decimate I also think
that people are underestimating the fact
that if you really got Palestinians
alone alone individually I bet you'd
find a lot of them saying I'd love to
get rid of Hamas I'd love to cuz they
people who are defending Hamas should
have to live under Hamas I wonder what
that's like when you're the average
Palestinian just trying to get their
your kids to school that that's got to
be um not so much of a picnic because
they control literally everything and
they steal everything and they'll give
you what you what you what this this is
what evil people do right we have this
we have this uh board here where you see
Andrew right part he talked about
Alinsky saw Alinsky 101 it's accuse the
other side of that exactly which is it
is that you're doing and that's what
they do they go look look look they're
bombing hospit no no you're bombing
hospitals look they killed civilians no
you targeted civilians it's the Amber
herd defense look I was abused no you
were physically abusive it's the
feminist defense oh my gosh I can't
believe look at how unfair no no hold on
a second you're using a system that is
unfair and you are abusing men this is
what we see all the time it's ch we see
it all the time by the way with uh um
child abuse right now with a trans issue
right you have these trans activists who
say hey we want to put a kid on puberty
blockers and give them access to sex
changes and the parents who say no they
say you're child abusers take the
children no no no no you're abusing
children no no Amber herd you abuse
Johnny Depp no no no Hamas you are the
ones violating your own human rights so
they blame you of doing exactly what it
is that they do do not underestimate the
art of projection from these people evil
people rarely come out and just say yeah
I'm starving my own people I'm not going
I'm going to make sure that they don't
have water because I want a photo op
Amber herd didn't come out and say yeah
I threw a bottle Johnny Depp and broke
his finger and took a in his bed no
they don't say yeah you know what we
don't care about the long-term
ramifications of your child go
undergoing hormone replacement therapy
or having a sex change where the suicide
rate attempted suicide rate actually
gets worse after this it's at least 42%
you know what we're doing it for a
political agenda and we're going to try
and take your kids away no they say if
you don't go on board with us it's child
abuse it is projection it is gaslighting
it's what they do mhm hamas's logo
should be should literally be instead of
a hang ladder should be
a lifeless Palestinian child being
pulled from Rubble cuz that's what Hamas
wants that is the actual photo op that
they use to put out there in the world
and that's how they get their their
advantage that's literally what they
would rather it's a death cult they
don't value human life no all right
speaking of cult let's go to the cult of
property taxes nice segue by the way if
you want to have a tip seg way if you
actually lifeless children to taxes yeah
well you know death in taxes baby well
you know my my grass died in the recent
uh drought it did so uh
if if you want to uh discuss an issue
like property taxes okay I get that it's
boring for a lot of people but guess it
really is kind of long-term theft you
don't actually get to own anything ever
and that's compounded by the fact that
you may not be able to actually own
homes in the future considering how uh
you know considering where the rates are
these days and uh where a credit score
is just to give you an idea um let's go
to property taxes there was something
else I was going to say but you know
what I don't I was distracted by jenet
Ellis why do they why do they what do
they have her on an old Acer laptop
webcam can't CNN get something can you
bring It Up full screen look at this and
these people on CN they they want to act
as though oh no no no we can't have you
know people online they're not
legitimate news outlets these are tax
dollar cameras these are tax dollar
terrible lighting oh God I mean you
can't even see like Casper I know I know
they cost $20,000 each god um I just got
distracted by you complaining about your
grass dying how do you think Gaza feels
without all that water well you know
what it's it's far away so I don't think
of it oh all right sorry I just i' like
to create some perspective yeah yeah
perspective because nothing's off limits
with Brian certainly not on Tuesdays
so I love those plugs home ownership
here right is a big deal for Americans
right it's part of the American dream
that's what a lot of people talk about
and I don't think that the American
dream is dead I think people have
shifted their priorities yeah and their
values to be clear um I you know what I
would love to do maybe we could put a
segment together with a jenz person uh
working often from home right Flex work
uh and have them work in a factory or on
the lines like a a boomer did who did
get by the way full benefits in pension
and have that person uh swap with a gen
Z person I bet you they would both say
hey I would rather take my current job
and position but again I I think a lot
of people who about the American
dream going away you're not working in a
Foundry for 30 something years and and
getting a pension in basic Bally a way
that allows you to live in a, 1400t home
and get two weeks of vacation so I do
get it that the deck uh is stacked the
cards are stacked against you I
understand that right now as far as the
wealth at the top um and these giant
corporations who are taking a bigger and
bigger piece of the pie without baking
new pies unlike medium-sized businesses
used to it's not a culture of free
enterprise it's a culture of of CEOs
giving themselves bonuses at the
taxpayer expense that's not lost on me
all right that being said if you believe
that the American dream is dead you're
probably looking in the wrong places
there are ways to make it work that
being said home ownership is a huge
component of that there is a problem
with that and it's property taxes it
makes it feel or seem or on paper act
and legally be defined I would argue
much more like renting so it's so bad in
places like Texas by the way you would
think a very free state that uh some
people now are finally stepping up
trying to fix it Texans want to own
their own property not win it from
government we must provide that by
eliminating property taxes in Texas okay
and he's a wheelchair guy he's getting
there so here's the thing that's good to
hear unfortunately if you don't pay your
property taxes now you don't own your
property anymore well they can come and
take it from you yeah they come and take
it from you literally at gunpoint you
could have paid for the house yes over
30 years let's make no mistake taxes are
they take your money and if you don't
give it to them people with guns take
you to jail yeah just to be clear and
those people with guns who will take you
to jail for not paying monthly something
that you already own many of those
people believe that you should not have
the right to own guns now I'm not saying
that you take I'm not saying that you
take out an AR-15 if someone tries to
collect you know property taxes or the
HOA shows up don't misinterpret it those
are worse so they're they're often a
local tax property taxes and they do
vary a lot depending on location so let
me give you a couple of quick numbers
average property tax in America is about
$3,800
okay that's lowest average tax bill is
Alabama $882 highest average tax bill
New York State
$112,000 okay these are averages that
I'm giving you now let me ask you this
before I move on what do you think
property taxes pay
for because I'm willing to bet that a
lot of people will say hey things like
roads police dep Department maybe fire
department you know things that you
would think are legitimate roles of
governments that are you know um
non-rivalrous right y these are terms
that people would use like okay there's
no incentive necessarily for private
Enterprise to get in there's no way to
necessarily make more money I would
argue that's not necessarily true with
things like roads but okay that's
probably what you believe let me go
through the claims versus the truth with
property tax here's a
claim they tell you that property taxes
are necessary for funding social
programs okay here's the truth the Lion
Share of your property taxes go to
schools now I know you're thinking hey
that must be a good thing right the
average is 40% across the country okay
the high is 89% of property taxes going
to schools all right so you might say
that's a good thing right we need Public
Schools it's the app it's the apple of
my eye yeah the Crown Jewel of the
United States what if I don't have kids
and I don't want to pay for school well
you know what you're out of luck I
have kids I'm just you know I know I
know they're not in school yet don't
want to pay for he has a wonderful beard
now you might think good okay so it's
not really going to roads it's not
really going to the police it's not
really going to uh fire department all
right but it's going to schools that's a
good thing okay so let's go to another
claim the only reason you would think
that's good is because you believe that
schools need more money to improve
education or you believe that more money
equals better Public
Schools here's the
truth
no and this is what if nothing else you
need to disabuse people of this notion
that money equals better schooling
because even people on the right when
they're running for office they go and
we need to fund our schools or you hear
people say money to Ukraine those
billions of dollars could be used to
even if you took every single dollar
that was spent right sent over to ukra
guess what it wouldn't help at all it
would not improve the metrics in public
schooling the way our schools are it's
it's actually incapable of improving
with increased funding yeah public
education is a public disaster to the
tune of trillions of dollars over the
last few decades right this is a
terrible way to spend money so your
property taxes largely going to schools
okay from 2000 to 2020 per pupil
spending in the United States went up
27% okay the average is
$116,000 per pupil we make all the
references publicly available okay so
$16,000 per pupil is the average
spending meaning per person in the class
okay went up 27% what do we have for
that more money better schools no
results the education performances by
all observable by everything
quantifiable plummeted we're worse off
more money and we are worse off from
2013 to 2022 scores went down fourth
grade math scores went down 2% reading
scores down
2% in the eighth grade math scores went
down 5% so it got worse reading scores
went down down 3% I don't even know how
if it already went down in the fourth
grade how are you even reading in the
eighth grade why is that even relevant
you got you should stay in forth I
didn't think you get to pass the SAT
scores think of how much money yeah the
lowest we've seen since 2005 wow
the lowest we have seen since 2005 and
we always say look to you know try to
look to an extreme example and sort of
scale it back from that okay let's get a
case study New York City okay so the uh
the median property tax in New York
$9,000 okay $991 right that's the median
it's the highest in the United States
the P pupil spending remember I just
gave you the average of $166,000 it's
$32,000 really close to $33,000 in New
York oh New York okay2 per per pupil yes
highest in the United States the result
half of third through 8th grade students
fill reading tests and think about this
for a second not only is reading
comprehension going down it's going down
at a time when people have more access
to literature than ever yeah but then
there's Tik Tok so it's hard to compete
exactly we never has a generation of
people had more tools at their disposal
and been less capable in the basic
fundamental skills of reading now this
isn't just talking about oh Zoomers no
the schools are obviously failing them
yes but so is our culture at large
half half 32,000 that means that if you
have you're spending $32,000 on that
child in New York City and there is a
50% chance that that
$332,000 has created an illiterate child
that's unbelievable $322,000 per so do
the math kindergarten first second third
you got about you know 20 $130,000
depending on where you are and can't
read yeah for that much money let's it
gets worse bad it gets worse worse yeah
it does it does get worse I know what
he's thinking Mr off's like I knew I
should have stayed home
today Baltimore okay per pupil spending
there is
$21,000 not as much as New York City but
you know it's not properties are less
valuable yeah you know I mean they're
you Bob's Big Boy and a couple of crack
houses a lot of crack hous is coming
back though they are coming back but
they don't pay a lot of property taxes
that's true yeah so it's the fourth
highest rate in the United States per
pupil spending what's the result again
property taxes most of the money goes to
schools let's go to the areas where they
spend more money on schools 40% of high
schools did not have this number is
going to shock you hold on on a single
student proficient in math what 40% of
high schools in the Baltimore area did
not have one single student proficient
in math just kidnap an Asian I was gonna
say get some get some Chinese students
in there 40 pull that back up is there
no Chinatown in bore I know right zero
look at that the article says it and
then to make sure at the very end not
one student to make sure that you
understand this is not hyperbole they
just one student give them more money
wow so we've given more money we've
given more money we're throwing money at
the problem more Tut T tutors and that
comes from your property taxes so when
you pay that check when you when you I
guess if you pay my check anymore it's
probably on autopay but the point
remains that's going to not one single
student proficient in math 30% of all
Baltimore high school students uh by the
way they have a graduation or sorry 30%
of all Baltimore high schools yeah they
have a graduation rate below 50% wow
what one of the high schools was 14% now
think about that you just talked about
the money let's say a kid goes through a
few grades you've now spent $90,000 on
them and they drop out anyway yeah you
thought Gaza was bad that's what we call
a societal loss leader my God it's like
college how is Baltimore a thing
anymore what are we what are we doing
here I thought Detroit was the worst
place it did used to be the worst it did
it did used to be the worst and by the
way hold my beer said Baltimore we could
maybe pull from I did a uh we'll pull it
later I did a a documentary Detroit and
ruins this was in 2009 or 2010 where I
talked about how children in uh Detroit
high schools and their per pupil
spending back then was higher than the
national average I think the national
average was around 10,000 I'm going by
Road I think Detroit was 13,000 that
shows you how much the spending has over
14 now in other words if there was
enough money uh Detroit schools would be
doing well yeah and a student who enters
into High School in Detroit freshman
enter has more chance of ending up in
prison than graduating right now I I had
that in the documentary I stand by it
completely I was fact checked you know
what they said no and this was the
Department of Education there in uh in
Michigan or the teachers unions and then
it was circulated through local I think
Fox Outlets or M live they said no
that's actually not true the vast
majority of of Detroit seniors graduate
high school I did not say seniors I said
someone entering into high school has
more of a chance there's a higher
likelihood that a end up in prison than
graduating high school the fact that the
teachers unions were involved in fact
checking me on that tells you that they
don't actually want what's best for your
kids why would I give a rat's ass about
the people who've already made it to
senior year it's a career we're talking
about a career average here yeah that
was back then think about that 14 %
graduation rate at a school in Baltimore
JZ 30% have rates below
50% that is ABS in at over $20,000 per
pupil we'll get into why that's the well
you know we'll go back to I don't want
to go to the guy at work right now he's
been trying to get in here so here's
another truth that you need to know if
more money worked
okay here's here's how liberals
manipulate leftists manipulate you
generally speaking you in your household
if you get more money you spend it on
that you need right you are allocating
money to things that you need so they
are banking on you making that logical
Assumption of the government that's not
true though that is not true when it's
not your money you don't spend it that
way you don't allocate it that way you
assume that more money means more
resources to to achieve the results that
you want so you paste that you copy
paste that to government more money must
mean they have more capabilities of
creating better schools they do not
here's
why
from 2000 to
2019 the hiring of Administrators is
what they place a prayer it far far
outpaced any uh type of growth in
student or teacher populations say is
this in high school yes it's across all
schol administrators they H more
administrators because they will say we
need more teachers per classroom but
that's not what they're doing yeah
they're hiring more administrators so
what do administrators do they they
fundraise bureaucracy yeah to give you
an idea as as far as when we're taking
schools collectively and how many people
are involved students teachers
administrators students and teachers
they make up about
10% of the population what 10%
administrative positions 87% so when
people say when you hear Barack Obama
growth that's the growth so just just to
be clear student and teacher population
grew by 10% the grow administrative
positions by almost
by7 that's insane real they have
outpaced them by so 87 to 10% their
growth respectively I don't mean that's
the total you probably should admonished
me on that well later I should have been
very clear that being said 87% growth in
administrators versus 10% growth in
teachers and students so when you hear
them say you know hey if you remember a
great teacher who changed your life go
and go and thank a teacher sure do do do
you do you remember a great a great vice
principal secretary nope who had an
impact on your life yeah I actually do I
actually do there was one her name was
her name was Mrs trainer she let me use
the whole punch when I was supposed to
be punished she let me use the whole
punch and then I open up I have a mask
well one does but it didn't change my
life no and it certainly wasn't worth
$32,000 a year so then you have the
administrator salaries also outpaced
teacher salaries the money is not going
to teachers so in 2023 the average
teacher salary was about
$68,400
12,650 and guys can you let me know is
that annualized or is that what they
actually make that's what they actually
make I believe that's what they actually
make which if you add in the 3 months
off if you add in the 3 months off
teachers aren't doing that badly that
means it's about $85,000 a year plus
full bennies Massachusetts the uh the
average was
$992,000 that's for the for a teacher or
for for a teacher rather months off
bring that overlay up really quickly the
one that we just did that had the
salaries in there you can read up in
there in the top on the left Mississippi
was at like 48,000 92,000
Massachusetts wow I mean I don't mind
the teachers are getting paid more it's
the administrators that are getting paid
more that the teachers are getting paid
more because of the stats we just quoted
on how poor students are doing listen
you get less pay until they do better
your children are illiterate so you get
nothing I bet you I but let's I know
it's a bigger issue teachers might be
fine it might be the parents that suck
lack of parents a good point but you
can't just come in and keep asking for
more money more money more money please
I agree yeah well it's across the board
though it's across the board the public
schools don't do a good job so an
administrator 102 ,000 of course and the
benefits the kind of benefits that you
can't possibly imagine unless you're
either a public sector worker educator
or administrator these hero hero say it
hero sorry true hero true hero true hero
and by the way you should be able to
work from home in Zoom because you know
if you if you show up with some some
kids who are you know have the sniffles
you're taking your life in your hands
yes pick a different career the roles of
these administr have almost nothing to
do with teaching your kids again this is
all about property taxes 79% of school
districts right with more we try to in
bigger districts they have more than
100,000 students they have a chief
diversity officer there you go they have
a what they have a chief diversity
officer to make sure like there's
there's a there's a equal number a bunch
of useless people of color in gy yes yes
I'm sure how how would you affect is it
the teachers that're they're supposed to
administrators to have I'm piing this as
an extreme example of absurdity because
people about Dei right and these
kinds of corporate scor but your
taxpayer you're your your property taxes
are paying for these absurd costs in
schools and then you have someone like a
chief diversity officer who by the way
let me give you an example Columbus Ohio
the city school uh Chief diversity off
$137,000 a year how does what I'm
getting her I'm getting whoever this
person is on off limits so I can so I
can push back how can how can children
not learn if not for a woke environment
that's how they FL they need to be led
by a chief like this yeah do we do I
guess we don't have it never mind oh
thank there it is nothing like being
late to the P they call her squats on F
I was ready with the off limits squats
on fist what squats on fist Brian said
off limits so and this is the other
problem too your property taxes are
funding propaganda yeah propaganda
concentration camps let's be really
clear what do you think happens when
your kids are being taught by a bunch of
teachers who refuse to go into work
because of Co you know right right there
you know where they line up politically
on that right they bought everything
Hook Line and Sinker public teacher they
supported the idea of vaccine mandates
of masking all your children which is by
the way created uh irreparable damage to
Children's social so being able to pick
up on social cues facial recognition we
have our own internal facial recognition
software they don't know how to interact
with people they they've suffered from
the highest uh mental health illness me
mental illness that we've seen in our
ENT addiction rates are through the roof
drug abuse alcohol abuse kids don't know
what to do when they get onto the
workforce so these teachers supported
that all the lockdown okay then you have
these entire unions and administrative
officials supporting Chief diversity
officer what kind of people do you think
are spending that
$32,000 a year of your taxpayer your
property taxes what kind of people do
you think are handling that money and
maybe that's why you're children are
illiterate are you sure about those
property taxes yeah and by the way
they're they have no problem making sure
that they have access to books that
describ sexual acts to four-year-old or
5-year-old sorry porn porn exactly
pornography right they literally have
pornography in the libraries that they
have to make sure that they go and spend
the money on those types things and
making sure that you can't complain
about it because then they call you the
cancellor which goes back to what you
said the solinsky tatic tactic we want
you to not have these books in there no
no no we're not trying to ban books
we're trying to ban pornography yeah but
Gerald animal sex can be dangerous if
not performed properly it's true you've
got you've got to Manicure the Target
first you've made a point that I can't
argue with but I feel like is irrelevant
yeah well it's not as long as it may be
irrelevant but it's not off limits yeah
it's not off limits oh my God you don't
know the world that they're living
in well look stop stop showing me
that and now you now that you said Steve
Jobs it's ruined everything no it's
awesome it's fantastic it's off limits
I'm glad you dished the black turtleneck
doily under your T-shirt today well I
had to show my wrestler's neck yeah
let's come on now is that a Russian
wrestler a baseball player's neck now I
don't know that and and I don't mean
that's not pre that's not the juice
baseball players
neck that's the 1950s baseball player
yes exactly where they're hitting 56 mph
fastball the kid is lean yeah not an
ounce of fat on him and I tell you he
really likes he has a pregame ritual
with a cigarette and one finger of
scotch he says that he's sharper on the
ball now let's review this again while
we go through property taxes okay you
never actually own anything because of
his property taxes all right in America
up to 89% of your property taxes go to
fun School are spending more money than
ever largely on administrative positions
Like Chief diversity officers while your
academic performance uh as it relates to
your children is dropping dramatically
two-thirds of American children cannot
read
good and your tax money is being used to
fund a completely failing system that is
indoctrinating kids about white
privilege Common Core math diversity
wokeness while they tell them that
American history is something they could
be triggering so we're not going to let
them know about the founding fathers God
there you go there you go are you
starting to realize the scheme when
people talk about a rigged game property
taxes is one of them and when when I say
we should defund the Federal Department
of Education you guys think that's
extreme I'm starting to think that most
State schools suck as well they
absolutely do and you know when you guys
talk about this I always try to acted
like you wasn't even talking he did I'm
so sorry but I want you to hold that cuz
I want you both to get it yeah I just
got so worked up CU J Gerald's goingon
to give his on limit comment yeah
this you're going start a new show
that's called on limits with a white
background in me and I don't need that
that's not going to happen yeah I can't
do that I'm sorry I'm sorry I so look
here here's the solution blow up the
Federal Department of Education we've
already talked about that but we need to
get rid of public careful we had a
literally yeah my God okay folks crying
out loud metaphorically dismember the
Federal Department of Education I don't
know um no don't physically do anything
I'm just saying the organization itself
needs to go away can't say that either
the problem that we have right now is
that it's not a money issue we've thrown
money at this problem for decades
literally trillions and trillions of
dollars wasted on public schooling what
we need to do is to type parents to the
success of their children again it is
not the responsibility of the government
to educate your children it is your
responsibility to make sure they're
prepared for Life period when you have
communities like this that we talked
about in Baltimore and New York that are
struggling like this those are
communities typically that live in
poverty and parents don't tend to pay
much attention to their kids schooling
and this does not absolve teachers and
administrators they are a huge part of
the problem because they know and then
they still ask for more money as though
that will solve the problem so right now
every single and there are problems with
this but talk through it every single
state now you have to sell every bus by
the way the bus that I rode to school
that didn't have a seat belt I know kids
I was always getting mixed messages they
were saying buckle up I'm like well all
I have is the safety bar of the seat in
front of me on my shows you that just
shows you back in the 1990s that the
money that you're spending on schools
that's how they innovate they're like ah
kids buses they could die in a car crash
we typically protect them with like
special seats and stuff in cars we don't
have enough to to getting curb stomped
on the bench in front of you is a
learning experience yeah but lesbian
suszie Q needs some more money and three
more months off apparently uh but seat
belts will get around to that right we
need to get rid of these things sell the
schools right now over time start
bringing in the private sector to
actually sorry the public sector to
actually start putting programs together
so that you can have better education
systems and we stop funding these things
all
together the education business and
here's why I know it works right parents
tend to pay a little bit of attention
when you're in public school right
they're like ah you got to get good
grades on your report card the minute
Mom and Dad start writing checks to a
college and they're like holy crap what
are you doing with this accountability
kicks in because now you're physically
writing the check it's not just property
taxes and you're not really sure where
it's going you're writing a check going
you're doing you failed how many classes
no no no no no no you're going to
Community College it works when you make
the parents responsible for what's going
on with their children guess what your
children and you can change it by the
way this is a Comm this is why your
local elections matter you can have a
direct impact on both your property
taxes where they go and how your schools
are being run that's something you can
do you can't control which which ass
hatch become speaker you really can't at
this point it's out of your hands what
is in your hands is the people who are
in your own backyard that taxes that you
pay your property taxes and holding
their feet to the fire yes Mr off well
I'm thinking about the fact that I'm
thinking about the fact I like that Mr
off liim is good I'm thinking about the
fact that it's when you have a a party a
political party that is aligned with
this kind of insanity from gender
ideology to uh giving more money
indiscriminate money to schools and
stuff how are you supposed to be in the
middle how are you in any way supposed
to say I'm Democrat heavy Republican
light that doesn't exist any anymore
you're either on the right or you are
far left and part of the insanity and
that's that's kind of the the uh so when
you say something I had a I had a guest
on my podcast off limits who said that
that he had worked for Biden said I
think Biden's a moderate the problem is
he may be temperamentally a moderate or
maybe historic if he's aligned with this
kind of stuff then he ain't a moderate
he is on the farle and he is a disaster
for this country and you only have one
choice which is to be all for don't call
me far right call me traditional and
sensible and on the side of Truth which
would be I don't know conservative but
you also what was funny is you said
gender indology I said indology and I
meant and I meant it because the Native
Americans chicks with
dick I see a parody
[Music]
song
oh
[Music]
and and I would love to hear from you
can comment below hit the like button
helps with the algorithm we're going to
go on the mug Club here in a little bit
before we get to what you just said
which ie agree with but you know that's
not going to happen I have had a call
out to anyone any actual representative
member of the teachers union because
their policy uh forbids them from
supporting this any member of the
democratic party who opposes this PO
anyone who actually carries some weight
as a legislative official or
representative I don't care if it's the
a the ADF whatever it is or the ADL or
uh what's the other one Southern Poverty
Law I don't anyone who actually in an
official Capac it opposes School
vouchers I've never heard an argument
against it I've never expressed it to
anyone who once they've understood it
has been against it we did white and uh
uh uh white and black on the gray issues
right black and white on the gray issues
with this one uh lady black lady and her
daughter who immediately went to every
single Trope they could imagine white
fragility check your white privilege
white guilt colonialism the nuclear
family is is is white supremacy and and
even they when I said well what about
school vouchers and they I said before
we change anything else before we go to
you know dismembering the Department of
Education before we go to Charter
Schools just make it so that the average
per pupil spending is attached to the
student and if you're willing to drive
or use your
bicycle or take a municipal bus you can
take that number that money to any
school you want that's the all just that
as the first change rather than money
goes to the school you go to the school
money attached to the student that's the
easiest first switch I have never heard
a single valid argument against it no
one has even presented it yet we don't
do it in this country it's incredible as
a matter of national policy when we talk
about common ground why don't we change
that tomorrow and do you know how I know
it's not that hard to do that's
effectively what happened where I was
raised in Canada I didn't realize until
I moved to the states there and Canada
sucks
but I went to a school that would have
been outside of my school a public
school I went to Centennial Regional
High School if I were in the states I
would have had to go to shamble high
that was the drug kid school they said
oh yeah if you're willing to get on this
bus or if your parents are willing to
drive you you can go to any of these
schools and guess what they were far
better than the United States still a
far cry from private schools or Charter
Schools it was so foreign to me when I
came to the states and I said wait when
I was looking at houses what does that
mean that they say oh that's the school
in your District I go you mean one of
they said no that's your school that's
the school if I live here I have to go
to that you don't have any choice n
that's a uniquely American for The
Shining City on a Hill that is a
uniquely American stain in our history
and it is not being changed because of
special interest group today and by the
way what's the proton mail maybe we can
have them reach out just like the lwc
tips at proton mail one legislative
official or let's say a member of a a
think tank as it relates to education
who can lay out the case for why a
school Voucher Program would be a bad
thing I've never heard it in my life I
am open to having my mind change our
school system as it exists right
now it doesn't work it's about as
useless as you know we brought him in as
an intern and now he's on retainer I
know what the argument they he's on
retainer you know we have we wanted to
get Charles Xavier and we got his
brother Chad and he's out there right
now we've had problems this morning is
he still there all right let's hey Tim
come here please like the printer isn't
printing
um it looks like something to do with
these uh cartridges being out of
alignment we probably got to change
[Applause]
them
[Music]
printer all right
yeah that was this morning that was
powerful um there's an argument I know
what the left would say with school
vouchers I know what they'd say they
would say racist no they would say no
the the problem with school vouchers is
the people that can afford to get on a
bus a bicycle or in a car and go to that
school would go to those good schools
and those schools would compete for
those dollars and get better and then
the PE kids that couldn't afford to it's
exactly the same argument they make for
the lack of a stu of an ID for voting or
for example why uh a lot of times they
should have voting on a different day
because people have to work and they
can't etc
etc I it doesn't hold water but I
understand the argument but Gerald I
wrote it down it ends public education
that's here's the thing that's exactly
agreeing but that's what they will say
but here's the thing it doesn't I'm not
even talking I'm saying before we get to
any type of private you're still
spending the same amount Baltimore sorry
New York City 32,000 per you're still
spending 32,000 per people I'm talking
about before scaling pack a dime just
make it so they have the choice and I
know and yes they'll say that but guess
what it still doesn't change the fact
that they're no worse off right now
correct if they right now if they do
have a parent or they do have the
ability to get into a bus or get in a
tandem bicycle guess what they still
have to go to that shitty school so if
you're saying that some people have such
awful parents have no bicycle have no
friends who will carple with them have
no ability to ride a bus and so and so
okay and so and what happens well they
end up at the exact same school where
they're forced to go now yeah no I my
point is it shines what it would do is
it would shine a light on really bad
schools and parents would not put up
with it and it would end the public
education system they don't say it ends
the public education system they would
say it's not fair because it would pull
money out of the public education system
and you're right it wouldn't it would
just transfer it and it would highlight
these guys are good y'all are really bad
and by the way you know what else could
happen the most likely scenario even if
that school where they're going right
now okay right now let's just all right
here let let me give you a visual a all
right here's get you whiteboard you guys
we should all run for office kid okay
here's a circle right now all right if
you can see Circle all right is it clear
good Circle it clear did it without a
compass all right so there you go right
now I have to I live here so I have to
go to this school all right okay now we
say hey wait a second school choice
voucher meaning a voucher meaning same
money is spent we're not cutting any
money all right right circle's a little
bit bigger now there's one two 3 stop a
boob big old titties you are adults
sorry sorry we are you're supposed to be
stop it Mr out of bounds take it take it
take it up with Mr off limits after the
show so right now you have to go to this
school so we just expand it and by the
way you might have a school that's only
five blocks away that you can't go to
all right so right now this school when
you're in this you're in this
scenario there's a little bit of nipple
here TS TS if you are in this scenario
there is no reason for that school to
improve right we at the very least we
know they have not improved test scores
have gone they never gotten better never
got it right they've had enough time
let's put it that way draw draw the
other one St it another SCH so now we
got I did do another school they're just
not big enough all right okay a you gots
on her tits you might want to go to a
doctor and get this I don't know if it's
so she's got the now let's say okay the
person has to drive a little further all
right they have to drive a little
further the argument is but if they
don't have parents with the car or if
they don't have an ability to take a bus
or okay so the assumption is this school
will take all of this school's money or
do you think the more likely scenario so
that this school avoids being shut down
for the first time in the history of
this school they might actually start
trying to provide better schooling and
even if it's not as good as school
number two three or four guess what
it'll be better than it is now there is
no real world scenario in which every
school doesn't improve to some degree it
would be impossible and you know what
happens if that school shuts down and
the other schools are to there'll be
another school that will open up still
taxpayer funded you and your property
taxes assuming that you still believe in
them and that we can't have actually
privatized school there is no scenario
in which anything gets worse it can only
improve anyone out there send in your
representative send anyone you have who
can make a cohesive argument that makes
any sense we are going to continue by
the way hopefully you know comment if
you guys like them sometimes we go we go
in deep diagrams are good what what what
happens when they go to the school
that's shaped like a vagina no no they
don't well here's the thing is if
they're going sometimes you have what
well sometimes and and then
have double School District but then you
can actually if you have a plane you can
privately hey hey that's off limits for
real hey nothing is off limits if you
like us not a hockey ring if you like us
going deep into these topics sometimes I
know everyone else is just talking about
the speakership everyone else is talking
about Hamas um we try and provide some
reference pieces for you all of the
sources are available at L credit.com we
are going to play Spot the transe I can
say that if you're on YouTube right now
so if you are on YouTube it doesn't
really matter if you're on Rumble click
this button below M you get to join mug
Club $89 annually you get this show you
get another full half of the show every
day you get a Friday show Alex Jones
Brian C off limits on Tuesday you get
the Hodge twins every week you have Mr
guns and we're adding more and more none
of this happens without you notice very
few sponsorships and we are demonetized
on YouTube and guess what no one else is
going to be doing a 35 minute segment on
property taxes and school
choice M thank you Rumble YouTu piss
off
[Applause]
what